pour vous les maintenances et vous est
ce qui va se passer sur le terrain qui
moi m'intéresse vous êtes bien dans
votre corps et biens dans votre tête moi
je ne suis pas du tout inquiet sur ce
qui va se passer maintenant
on compte sur vous comme vous pouvez
compter sur nous à six mois ça ne sert
d'en face au ghana
[Musique]
quoi
g
c'est pourquoi ankara devant bush
j'ai vu jouer les familles pour lui
gagner les mamies poussins
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
et quand je
[Musique]
voilà
ohé
marrant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avant
on
[Applaudissements]
le coup d'envoi de cette rencontre qui
va opposer dont baby foot face au
thunder valley d'ici quelques secondes
nous voulons réveiller président de l'as
saint-etienne alain perrin
c'est parti un peu distant s'il vous
plaît
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
simone arriva
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
regardez
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas grave c'est pas grave savard à
la relance allait prochainement
on va se prendre 40 là il ya 3 0 la
norme a tancé par le brésil voilà les
trois mois trois ou quatre ans
ces candidates
trente ans
on ne peut pas partager les bonnes entre
antibes et amélie mais c'est pas grave
ça c'est l'expérience qui concerne
[Applaudissements]
on entend des choses on va toujours aux
baisses la de frapper au but
allez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça démarre ça fait mal à passer
ils ont du jeu john m c'est fort hein
quand il attaque qu'il faudra mais il se
regroupe bien nous mais pas celle où toi
nous sommes qui manque d'humour toujours
[Musique]
aussi bon
à temps c'était 10 à 0 1ère partie et
ensuite
bravo les coach qui en seconde partie en
dimon a vu le niveau on va les mélanger
et là c'est extraordinaire on savait
plus qui était qui m'enfin on a joué et
là derrière ma qui a marqué un but m'a
dit ce but je les marque et parce que
l'ami africaine m'a laissé le marc hé tu
vois jusqu'où va la finesse la
délicatesse elles se sont dit allez pour
l'honneur les centres vhu fabuleux il
fallait y penser il fallait avoir la
courtoisie j'ai pas la grandeur d'âme et
la générosité de nous laisser au moins
ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
une sud africaine m'a dit je suis
heureuse d'être vieille et là ça va tu
vois ça c'est beau et je crois qu'il
faut plus parler d'âge
regardez c'est le côté une fraternelle
parce qu on est tous pareils avoue que
tout ce qu'on a nous ici est elle là bas
faire l'échangé faire un groupe sans
animosité rire le côté humain ça sera ma
chère